do you guys foresee a future of marriage
between the two of y'all
but me answer and say no
can't believe a marriage so no so you
don't believe in marriage because you've
never been married before right blue no
so it's just something you're just not
like I just don't see the point yeah it
doesn't make it yeah I I respect it but
I'm getting married though you're
getting married to somebody
um yeah it's the first one somebody
will it be hard to find somebody if your
ex's face is tattooed on your neck
I'm just I'm just I'm just curious
it should be him right it should be
that wouldn't even make sense what
yeah I don't know I don't know what what
we would have for that I don't know but
what are the tattoos that's why I be
confused I'd be like
are you confused
are you gonna get a croissant tattoo or
do you have one he's not breaking up
like why are you why are you see me
breaking up he's saying shut up he said
how are you gonna find somebody
with your ex tattooed on it I already
found you I'm cool she's already got it
man
now she just has to convince you to walk
down the aisle
I'm not convincing nobody to do [__]
that's not what we want to do yeah
I just don't care for the paperwork